gang you only got three more chances to
see are you garbage live yeah guys
december 14th 15th and 16th we're going
to be in hartford connecticut at the
funny bone we're going to be in albany
new york at the funny bone that we're
going to be in syracuse new york at the
funny bone as well
guys this is a great way to introduce
your friends to the show if you're
coming bring a couple of pounds bring
this squad it's a good time it's stand
up we're hanging out play auig you've
seen the clips what are you doing come
out we'll see you there let's go
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage there is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they go to be classy
yeah after just a big old piece of [ __ ]
you don't say i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here in aunt toddy's basement she's
upstairs trying to get some people
together okay for what she wants to do
one of those smash and grab jobs that
everyone's doing all over the country i
get the louis vuitton or something yeah
she wants it to louis vuitton i told her
we were in i don't know okay i gotta do
something around the holidays together
i think i broke my mask with me
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table so you know it's a family app
circle in the wagons kj is in the
building everybody hey gang happy to be
here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate me if you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true the roof true the [ __ ] we've
been saying it for a year those numbers
are true though
closing in on 30 000. get us over 30
thousand even if you listen hit this go
subscribe go subscribe because we may or
may not have a special project coming
out pretty soon on a used to yikes
leaking it check it out you got a t you
gotta leave some bread crumbs like toby
mcguire on the set of spiderman i'm like
toby mcmuffin on this side of ayg
uh and then obviously patreon.com you
can sign up you get a bunch of bonus
content episodes of ayg episodes of hard
feelings which is the the breakout hit
by the way oh everybody loves it
everybody
khan's talking about it khan scotch
uh
live streams the whole nine yards check
it out
that's cooking over there
and how about a nice shout out to you
know our producer shorten there good kid
wearing a bernie's it starts with uh
t-bone that's right wearing a nice
barney's crew neck that he got on the
ayg pre-sale ooh
yeah i paid full price like an answer
hey you got 20 on the back end
tough break ticket
hey business is business all right
blood sticker and water other things
oh my god toby tebow it's good to see
you buddy we had a nice ride in i love
both of you um you have never been
louder in a car ride
in our entire end friendship um yeah i'm
moaning a lot i started with the trainer
we got a bump plug in what's happening
someone got the remote control at home
what's happening dude let me know huh
do you ever see those videos i mean my
girlfriend are playing hunger games
right now
[Laughter]
no i never saw those videos me either
what were we talking about
that's what you like electronics
jesus
[ __ ] creep not at all i don't know
why you think when i say have you seen
something you automatically think it's
my thing that internet's a pretty big
place i got a lot of videos on there
every now and then something comes
across my screen i wasn't ready for or
i'll peruse to see what the kids are
doing do a little window shopping kick
the tires on something see what's
cooking i wanted to ask you this what
little step back from your pornography
um
i was talking about youtube
you like do you like the car battery
hooked up to the nipples
you hear what kippy's doing he stuck his
dick in a vcr
those videos were private i was hacked
that's deep fake right there [ __ ]
shout out to steve jobs come on what are
we doing um i noticed this what'd you
notice there big guy uh thanksgiving i
noticed this
um i wanted to get your barometer on it
whether you think it's i don't know
short okay
this is gonna be a silly one i can
already tell like a turkey neck um
how do you feel about gizzards
gizzards can be all right are you a
chicken livers man listen you know me a
long time you won't do a little pate a
little chicken liver on a nice cristina
i'll do a beef pate
that's a that's that's a joke from rev
run
that really is
get his own mtv show no big deal
continue multiple beverages why
someone's eating not at a restaurant i'm
talking at dinner and oh that's insane
like you know like a glass of wine but
then like a soda
a thing of water
it's very jersey shore remember those
dirt balls are always drinking gatorade
at their every meal sure they always had
a bottle say hi these kids are in a gym
you know what i mean
that's true uh no that's real trash i
think like what we would do we do like
the big if we if we're doing like a din
dam like a sunday night dindin i got the
families coming together got the leaf on
the table the whole thing you sit at
that dining room table that we record at
the intro for are you garbage out yeah
we'll do that you do yeah yeah yeah
um
and then the kids will be out in the
kitchen you know right uh we'll be there
it'll be like everybody will be having a
drink beforehand right like me and my
brother probably doing a beer
brother-in-law doing a beer ladies are
doing wines uh my stepdad's doing
everything
um
and then it'll be like they'll probably
you know pour waters at the table like
you know everybody will have like a
water for you no one ever touches that
though nah rarely
we're not a beer yeah it's always warm
and [ __ ] uh we'll do a water at the
table and then that's about it sometimes
like my brother might change the wine so
there might but it's it's more
you know traditional it's not like you
know no one's got like a [ __ ] milk a
you know a glacier freeze and a [ __ ]
diet coke my one cousin it looked like
[ __ ] the front of a hot dog cart
he's got he's got those [ __ ] ketchup
bottles in the mud
a little bit of relish um that was on my
mind yeah and this has to annoy you how
do you feel about people is it you
by the way you're thinking about my cool
hat it's cool you've had listen you
really went hat shopping in hawaii i did
really good i got four hats i got new
pants i got a bunch of shirts because
you were giving me [ __ ] saying that that
i gotta up up my appearance now i'm
looking cool i got some cologne going
now that'll make it look real cool
that'll hide the frito smell how do you
feel i don't need fritos anymore how do
you feel about
god
i'm doritos light now
do diet doritos i'm on baked ladies
i remember the scam they they try to
pull the wool over everybody those
things can kick rocks man i'll punch the
guy who invented those right in the
[ __ ] face big blaze my mom oh i'd
rather eat bait
[Laughter]
hey dude me a night crawler
[ __ ] get out of here my mom rolled in
with those remember when they were they
were doing the chips in like a different
kind of oil
yeah that was big yeah the earth they
found that like ate your liver or
something like that
[ __ ] ugly well what was this yeah it
was like castle something asteroid not
castor oil but it was something like
that it was something that's the rules
for like ball bearings isn't it uh no
castor oil is when you have to throw up
or poop or something like that it's like
an old school remedy okay my mom poured
some down my throat one time
sounds like one of my videos
guys we're having fun over here a good
time um no it was either that or if a
cat one of them makes you throw up no
ipicac does yeah she did that esther oil
is like an oil
oh okay for your shoes i drank a whole
bottle of
trying to kill time what are you what
are you doing over there yeah it's for
stain and decks uh castor oil is a
vegetable oil pressed from castor beans
i don't even know what the [ __ ] that is
jesus
it's colorless and barely parallel
yellow liquid with a distinct taste and
odor and then it's just a bunch of
dummies eating this [ __ ] for whatever
benefits yeah this seems very crystals
yeah it's got a little yeah
homeopathic well ipecac works because i
puked everywhere yeah that's what that
stuff does i drank a whole bottle of uh
cough medicine when i was a kid robo
tripping
trying to take the edge off
mom
art class is killing me
got a real deep episode of care bears
cool off a little bit yeah she got on
top of me like a wrestler and [ __ ]
ping me down and poured it down my
throat he does that to me too
okay this broad was screwy in the 80s
screw balls see if this [ __ ] is snake
oil
it's castor oil yeah these are the top
uses it's a powerful laxative with
that's your leading off with that's
crazy a natural moisturizer so getting
your liquid inside and out yeah uh
promotes wound healing yeah it's all
real vague stuff
if you're pouring oil in wounds that's
nervous that's not that's calling it
wounds is bad
like you're dead anyway reduces acne
fights fungus
and keeps your hair and scalp healthy
all right so fully on the toes kipping
on the donkey bat recycle i like it
um a lot no please no please eating ice
whatever how do you feel
i love it we've gone over this chomp ice
yeah cram a crushed man through and
through oh
obviously also that's dessert i forget
where we heard it but it was real
garbage of somebody saying a place has
good ice which we both do oh yeah they
have the good ice that's real trashy but
great
uh one thing i wanted to run by it which
was uh lay it on me slick uh brought to
my attention
um
calling something top of the line top of
the line real trash
top of the line is trash i was looking
at i was looking at cabins to rent and
uh you know just like hole-in-the-wall
cabins
and uh there was a one with a hot tub
and it said fully equipped with the top
of the line hot dump they didn't even
have a lid on this thing
i feel like whoever it was leaves it
whoever wrote that had a toothpick in
their mouth
pop it alive
fit eight bodies in this hot dump
in here anything anything you call top
of the line is not top of that what's
top of the line give me a top of the
line uh item
makita drills makita drills milwaukee
milwaukee top of the line
yeah but i think
listen this okay i'm gonna break it down
for you
things are tough
yeah but you wouldn't you you know
mercedes is top of the line so you don't
need to say top of the line your call
when you say top of the line means it's
not top of the line you're going hyundai
top of the line automobile right there
oldsmobile
yeah it's not mercedes is i've never
known anybody there he
is forte smoke great for itself that's a
new giveaway by the way
you can take over my lease
tap it a line top of the line would be
it's something that's not top of the
line you're trying to tell sony's top of
the line yeah but you just say it's sony
that's what i'm saying sony speaks for
itself thank you
to me is top of the line yeah you
wouldn't say it's top of the top of the
line means it's middle of the road and
you're trying to pull the wool over it's
like kirkland signature brands top of
the line yeah make a good pair of jeans
yeah
what yeah you never go to everybody buy
clothes at costco i've never been to
costco
maybe once or twice what yeah we were a
sam's club household growing up
maybe
for like back-to-back yeah no growing up
they weren't even existence when i was
growing up that was that was [ __ ]
truck driver [ __ ] if you went to costco
it's still you went to costco in the 80s
you were you were a dirt ball yeah you
had to see it that didn't start hitting
until the 90s
[ __ ] that
we went my stepdad had one in the 80s or
had one had a sam's club card in the 80s
or nine i thought you had to like own a
restaurant back then to [ __ ] get in
there that's what i thought i think he
pulled the wool over you know he's
that's like definitely buy some hotel
pants yes
some bus boy cars
[Laughter]
room service trays
get one of those little bars on wheels
that moves around
so i want to get for the house i want to
get a top-of-the-line bar gun you do
yeah you strike me as a bar in the globe
kind of guy no that that's one of those
that's top of the line that's something
you think
classy and brookstone's [ __ ] and they're
stopping hardcore trash
online drone dude if you're it's 20 21
if you got a globe in your house it's a
dead giveaway there's booze in it and
it's all probably half empty you know
what i mean it's like
you got a bottle you got like a bottle
of makers or something a couple of white
claws in there something top of the line
yeah makers is top of the line
ah it's a middle i don't know i don't
know enough about are you still boozing
no i two beers last night at the show
but i last saturday
what's two beers
alcohol
yeah that's not boozing
you would have said when was the last
time you had beers i would have told you
two beers is not boozing trying to
figure out what to get you for christmas
you're tough to shop for
yeah you know
what are you smiling at nothing that
makes you think you're getting me
something real good
i don't know what you're talking about
really do you know how to pronounce
anything that rhymes with schmolex
schmolex oh really
that'd be nice oh one yeah hey listen
call navy federal i've been keeping you
pretty nice the past six months all
right
navy federal appreciates it
got kippy taking some of the load here
um
if you gave him a rolex his response
would be this is gonna look real nice in
the window of the pawn shop
you got to stay liquid around the
holidays
i don't know what to tell you yeah the
resale value of those things are neutral
i was going to reach out to our friend
paul verzi and find out what kind of
watch to get and i was thinking about
maybe picking up a watch over there in
parlez-vous francais yeah get something
cool french top of the line over there
you buy it under a guy in a trench kit
guy if you buy it from a guy in a trench
coat under the eiffel tower
you know where i can buy watches
hello um no like a french i'm gonna do a
little research what's a cool french
watch company something that these bums
over here will have when i see him on
the scene
because as you know i'm tightening
everything up yeah new pants everything
[ __ ]
next stop hollywood
hey i got new paints that i'm going to
wear every day for the next six months i
tell you before you give me a hat
that's a nice hat yeah cool that's rvccn
it's ru whatever yeah something cool
surf company yeah
i believe it is ruka yeah r-u-c-a
r-u-c-a really yeah it's a you i believe
yeah i gotta i got some ruckus come on
what are you doing you know i'm a ruka
man pick up a couple sponsors it'd be
nice we're chock full of sponsors i got
ladder i got me on there i got
expressvpn what do you need get me
invitational
riding the helix on the sidewalk
you're on a california king
hanging 10.
where's foley you're out there sleeping
that's how we do it
uh
gotta shake them down by the way hill
helix why i need a mattress i just
bought one yesterday you bought one i
bought a king size match what do you do
with your old one why do you want it
all fair we'll talk it's it's a gift for
somebody
would that be [ __ ] up if i gave him a
username if you gave him a free used
mattress from me yeah that
who i'm sorry can i help you who is it
for
if it's not for the homeless guy down
the block i'd rather not say it
who knows say it toby cut no i will not
say it
no you were going to give your parents
my old
mom
shut up
[Laughter]
she don't know it wouldn't be the first
time she was on it
i can't eat patties
patty it's the holidays i'm all hopped
up on nutty irishman you take that [ __ ]
down from this bald [ __ ]
come up here and scull you
hate to rib ya real quick he tuned you
up
goddamn veteran
[ __ ] dirt ball
run in your mouth
kim he's trying so hard not to spit on
his computer
who cares you got the new one coming in
anyway by the way holy [ __ ] bald [ __ ]
was the biggest thing you've ever said
to me
give it a couple of days a couple of
these workouts
you bald [ __ ]
wow
that's like you that that's out there
with that tub as [ __ ]
that tubby [ __ ] it's great
hey
the lord ass will sting you too that'll
put you on your heels look out oh my god
bald carry your lard ass just rattled me
dude
lard ass you weren't trying to be funny
bald [ __ ] is just that you fat [ __ ] i'm
talking about fornicating with my mother
on a used mattress
anywho back to business i need
we can put the screws on to get one no
we can't why not
what
no
no
uh i thought we could put this i thought
they just re-upped i thought get a new
one every campaign no
make a little fort in here
dams.comstance.comstamps.com i love
stamps.com stamp.com gang you don't want
to be wasting time in the post office
use stamps.com especially around the
holidays right he's jam-packed in there
oh my god forgets like 100 degrees in
there you got some bad sweater on do it
all from the privacy and the comfort of
your own home yeah guys whether you're
selling online running an office or a
side hustle stamps.com can save you so
much time money and stress during the
holidays you get access to all post
office and ups shipping services you
need without taking the trip to the post
office you gotta look for parking you
gotta wait in line we use it i'm a big
stamps.com guy love it i got the printer
i sent out all the cards the merch that
way ppp prints it all out easy peasy
yeah uh you'll save time and money
you'll be wondering why you didn't do it
sooner uh sign up with promo code
garbage for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts required just
go to stamps.com clip click the
microphone at the top click on the mic
enter promo code garbage one more time
stance.com promo code garbage do it yeah
kip let's talk about decked decked i'm
talking about decked drawer system
for your pickup truck for your work
truck weatherproof organized i remember
when i was a a lonely a lowly laborer
yeah working for a contractor uh-huh
always had to have the truck spotlessly
clean if tools went flying around
believe me i would hear it from this guy
yeah he was a real
dick
this guy belonged on deck.com and if he
would have had decked he wouldn't have
been busting my chops because the van in
the truck would have been would have
been organized yeah it's weatherproof
keeps your stuff safe from the rain ice
snow makes organizing and accessing
everything you need much easier uh they
have two full-length bed drawers can
carry up to 200 pounds or whatever you
got so it's built tough baby you got to
do it um they were nice enough obviously
we don't have pickup trucks we live in a
city you can't have a pickup truck in a
city should be a sweet tea though uh did
they oh that's right they did uh and a
koozie they got cozies that's all kind
of company yeah uh they were nice enough
to send us one of these systems i gave
it to my stepdad he's he thinks he's
like king [ __ ] at the job site yeah he's
like oh let me check my deck.com drawers
it looks cool yeah he's just like oh let
me think i think the keys are over here
the whole nine yards uh getting deck was
the best thing to happen to his truck
especially this time of year you know
what i mean you got to be flexing on
people that's right um protect your
stuff uh cold hammer
get deck drawer system at deck.com
garbage and get free shipping that's
deck.com garbage for free shipping on
your decked drawer system deck.com
garbage do it now yeah all right let's
get into it this is let's [ __ ] this
family episode guys so as you know when
you sign up for patreon we'll answer
your questions on that that's right you
choose it's time to play
who wants to be a piece of trash oh i
love that guy yeah he's a good guy that
movie [ __ ] rocks yeah i don't know
how they got those little kids to do
that talking about slumdog millionaire
if you haven't seen the film do yourself
a favor it's a hot hot piece of film uh
guys so as you know like i said before i
was rudely interrupted by this fat [ __ ]
i remember my wrestling coach uh
i was getting [ __ ] just we were like
doing something like really long like
endurance drills
and i was i was like a sophomore [ __ ]
still had my [ __ ] baby
100 meter jog
[Laughter]
the 200 meter nap
the 400 meter cramp what are we doing i
did really good in the five-step relay
race
um
there's like some seniors some kid that
ended up going to the naval academy i
was wrestling and he was [ __ ]
twisting me up like a pretzel and my
shirt was like up like my tits were out
and like my gut and like he had me like
stretched out like that and my assistant
wrestling coach walked by he's like yeah
get his fat ass
i'm sorry
i didn't sign up for this
um
i thought we'd wear makeup and hit each
other with chairs
where's the butt plug
guys so when you sign up for patreon
we'll answer your question on the air we
got some [ __ ] heaters uh worked
through most of the backlog by the way
they're only a handful of people it's
you know it's tough some people ask
questions backlog's trashy too when you
say i backlogged we got a backlog
when you said
a lot of things you say sounds trashy
because your garbage vodka oh that one
hit me vodka without a d vodka
kuvaka sodas oh some drunk vodka
absolute and tonic ugh that's a nicey
special vodka red bull that's the
[ __ ]
yeah that's what they drink in the hall
of fame at trash
i used to love that yeah vodka sodium a
little
nice
okay
talking about the holidays but i digress
yeah um so first one coming in from
speaking of sleeping this is a pretty
good one nice never thought of this this
is from jesse when you would sleep over
at someone's house would you shower
there or wait till you got back to your
house
it's weird i remember having a shower at
a couple kids houses
cause it's something and you're just
being like
it's like it's like being in another
dimension you're like what kind of soap
are you using you're in a bad hotel oh
yeah
so
i've had rich friends that i wanted to
get in there yeah like [ __ ] real nice
mom had the real expensive towels nice
macy towels body wash first time i used
body wash was not in my home no patty
foley did not buy body wash sure until
her back was up against the wall well
they got that got real commercialized in
the 90s like late 90s and stuff
you know and before it was time to get
your hands on i had to go to a specialty
shop or something it wasn't just that
the super fresh
that herbal essence when that hit the
streets man that was i mean i use that
as everything i brushed my teeth in that
[ __ ] yeah man [ __ ] hot chicks and
flowers come on haha man i'm all those
topless broads they got real dude that
framing was those commercials real
seductive give kippy a little stinger
yeah girl with the curly red hair
that and some of the irish spring
commercials with those broads here we go
we're out there in the the dewey meadows
sweaters sweaters really turn you on huh
sweaters and jeff caps
give me a sheep and a cane you know what
i mean
[Laughter]
um
by the way real quick ian called me the
other day been calling me non-stop my
good friend in finance i hey how's your
back feeling he's like i'm off the cane
i'm off the king
shout out to in fighting shout out to mr
fidanz um
so to answer your question great
brilliant question by the way
um when that when it was a nice house i
was all about i would stay there i want
to stay there for the weekend
you know what i mean trouble at home
just letting things cool off um my mom
used to get real pissed about that too
she wasn't a fan of me sleeping out why
don't you want to be here don't you want
to be here
she's really taking a lot of heat these
days yeah i apologize i love you patty
sounds like you're working through some
stuff
i said dying broad's opening up some
doors i'll tell you that right now that
have been closed for a very long time uh
we always had the one or two houses like
we i would only it was like you would
only shower
if you were
i guess it'd be like there's usually no
need for a shower out of
you shouldn't be there that long that's
no why would you yeah just a regular
under the middle sleepover you're
getting picked up at like 11 o'clock in
the morning after breakfast if that was
the norm for this kid there's something
with something else going on yeah there
was a vhs camera somewhere
high up on an angle yeah nobody's
showering yeah no that's too weird i've
definitely done it i remember i can like
picture beating in at that when you're
that young and you're in someone else's
shower it's an away game you don't know
what's happening
if you're talking childhood sleepovers
that's one thing no you shouldn't be
showering they drop you off at six you
have your pizza throw [ __ ] gremlins
in [ __ ] play the video games lay down
goof around bump up up up on you get up
there's breakfast and you're out the
[ __ ] door yeah what'd you say
oh yeah a little touchy-touchy huh a
little grabby grabby i don't know how
you just did it
but if it's a high school sleepover
unless you got to go to workers like if
you don't like you like say like your
parents went out of town and like pat
everybody ended up crashing at your
place after the party oh out of town if
they got to go to work like say he gotta
go to a shift at the grocery store hey
care if i grab a shower before i go to
work yeah of course yeah that's normal
yeah yeah but you shouldn't what if i
came home from a [ __ ] sleepover
showered with your hair done
new set of drawers
my underwear on backwards oh man they
would have been in the car [ __ ]
killing people you crazy
yeah no can't do that
um
nuts yeah it's wild you ever have
friends growing up
i think that's the second time you made
that joke about a year ago hit just as
hard too
did you do anything like that i don't
remember i i like vaguely remember
showering at friends places and then
like getting out and getting dressed as
quickly as possible like feeling like
that's like you still got
yeah it's like i want to be naked for as
little time as humanly put
that's another thing too it's but now i
can never do i can't get i can't shower
and get dressed in the bathroom that's
that's psychotic
i gotta walk out let the cold there hit
me i need my i walk around my apartment
naked while i'm getting ready you gotta
let the air get you oh yeah i need space
the thought of [ __ ] shouting and
getting dressed in a bathroom i mean
that's like prison
yeah i've done it bonkos uh
yeah i can do it but then yeah you're
you only only when you're real [ __ ]
hemmed up if you walk out of the
bathroom with your shoes on that's a bad
one
shoes and socks on me and kimmy were
talking about this at dinner have you
ever
if you for sure changed in a public
bathroom dude buddy we were [ __ ]
changing i was shaving in between
auditions at chipotle's [ __ ] brutal
so this was our question so anytime
we've done that me and kippy will take
our shoes off and then stand on our
shoes [ __ ] yeah was that was that your
move or were you would you go socks on
the floor well i mean you know at a
certain point
when you're living in there yeah uh what
do you get when you when you become so
desperate
you know you abandon
humility yeah
i'm shaving in a chipotle bathroom i can
put my socks on the floor a little more
glock
so i like to use this aftershave i know
it's more expensive
i know it's an additional 50 cent just
give me the guac shaving with a tortilla
chip
um they used to do this from my old day
job that i used to have there before the
great folks over there and thank you
shower.com
take a shower
no people would brush their teeth in the
bathroom
which i get like after lunch or whatever
but like i'm talking dude this bathroom
so it was a high rise
uh on you know on central park south
like you know it was like a high-rise so
it's like not a lot of [ __ ] space
these bathrooms are tiny there was one
urinal and like your shoulders could
touch like the wall and the
the guard for the stall there was two
stalls that were not a good place for
the deuce i would say bad spot for the
deuce then sometimes you're in there
both people are deucing someone's pain
there'll be a guy brushing his teeth and
i'm like bro like my [ __ ] is open
six feet away from you this is just like
it would [ __ ] get one of those wisps
things those wisps or some [ __ ]
mouthwash yeah but like this one guy was
just in there all the time doing it was
insane oh god yeah yeah i did not i
can't do that that's crazy can't stand
other other men's poops
women's will knock you on your socks too
every once in a while but another man's
uh something about it yeah it's uh you
feel like yeah it's way too intimate i
feel like i have to poop so my smell
dominates
maybe that's what bears do i don't know
i don't know much about the grizzly
the north american fat ass
the north american fans
guys we're having a good time today that
is to maximus
um say well let's stay in the bedroom
while we're here this is from uh
this is from joseph first time long time
i like that they're doing that uh first
time a long time when taking a shower
where do you put put the towel do you
put it on top of the toilet with the
toilet seat down like a bozo or the
towel rack like a gentleman what's your
standard operating procedure standard
operating procedure is i tend to uh get
water everywhere sure can i get yelled
at for it i can imagine yeah it's it's
like it's like a like a self-serve car
wash um
so i have a little hook that could that
she put next to the like all i have to
do is open the curtain
grab the towel sure and i dry off a
little bit in the tub yeah i don't just
step out like an [ __ ] uh-huh i used
to i did that up until
uh
i didn't know i don't i guess i had bad
parents or no one told me that you're
supposed to like dry off
kind of in the shower or but like on i
would literally
because we always had carpet in the
bathroom when i was a kid so i right on
it roll around
[Laughter]
using that as a towel it's a good
exfoliator too
um
i didn't know until my grandparents i
mean we were yeah i was probably in like
junior high
and
my grandparents were staying with us and
we had a share of like the bathroom in
the hallway they would use as well oh
that's always a rough time yeah the
dentures and the [ __ ] sitting there
small grandpa's dumps
man talking about the holidays holy um
yikes so
he uh
my grandmom goes
there's world war ii vets they just [ __ ]
different i don't know why
they got the old spice they don't even
make anymore yeah mix that in with a
little [ __ ] stroganoff or whatever he
had last night for dinner
yikes those are very corny um
no my grandma finally said to me one
time she was like what are you doing in
the bathroom and i'm like what did i
just comb in my hair
i was shaving
i was jerking off all right jesus christ
if i could grill me over here i was
slapping it
that's that's so funny just to go to
your grandma i was jerking off yeah i
was wailing away on myself
[Laughter]
i was hammering in the nails i got to
spell it out for you
what the [ __ ] do you think i was doing
there you dumb broad
i was re-caulking the tub
at one point you were just naming like
actual
home improvement thing
i was putting in a skylight
we're gonna get two [ __ ] two
questions get the bathroom read done
when you remember they'd come far and
wide
to look at your new [ __ ] shower
curtain
[Laughter]
family
up the upstairs bathroom for us was all
you don't go upstairs who doesn't like
when we uh we would have guests over
what do you mean guess
like when we were entertaining you never
went upstairs at someone like movie
stars and stuff you're [ __ ] talking
about your other dirtbag family members
is those your guests hear that guy he's
calling you dirtbags
they know what they are
come on yes yes they do why i love them
meet me at seams we'll get a slice
um
guess what who's who's a guest you just
didn't go upstairs
do you guys where you the kids weren't
playing in the rooms and it'd be a
little that's where the coats went yeah
the coats went on a bed upstairs yeah
but you don't like you want to like get
that you weren't going from like room to
room peeking that's private areas really
yeah bunch of weirdos now so say i'm a
cousin yeah i got to take a dump how old
are you
i'm 45.
you're my 45 year old cousin over my
house now oh i think and you gotta take
a dump no i'm in college
i'm at your house you gotta drop a
heater at dinner do i have to ask niecy
if i can go upstairs and [ __ ] squat
one out
no i feel that's you shouldn't be
dumping at a family dinner though what
if you gotta poop what are you going to
do i'm not saying sure
what i don't know if i've ever pooped at
a cousin's house like that
pooped
anywhere and everywhere bro i understand
i'm not one to like by by all means i'll
pull the trigger okay so let me ask you
at the airport today so i'm your cousin
shout out to the [ __ ] newark
international say i'm your say i'm your
cousin i'm over for thanksgiving yeah i
assume you would go up you would go
upstairs to that bathroom okay so what
if i just went upstairs and and peed hey
i gotta pee real quick you okay with
that yeah of course okay so it's not off
limits what are you talking about uh
yeah i'm not rooting through the panty
drawer yeah i'm not yes if you're going
i'm saying if you're not going out there
to use the bathroom there's no other
reason to be up there is what i'm saying
i'm not saying it's off limits but like
absolutely you're not gonna be like okay
what's going on upstairs yeah you're not
just [ __ ] hanging out upstairs a
party is downstairs yeah you're looking
for something you're looking for some
root canal medicine that's what you're
looking for um
but uh
back to i
what the kid knows what i'm talking
about
yeah she's called drug seeking behavior
then what do you break an ankle recently
i used to always keep that in the back
of my mind
who's getting there who's getting their
wisdom teeth out am i right
i'd have that schedule lined up is that
knee still hurt from college or what's
going on
man
at the beginning of that whole thing
they didn't know what was going on you
opened up anybody's medicine cabinet it
was like
open up a closet you see a walking boot
whose crutches are those
are those crutches fresh or what's going
on checking the bottoms of it to see how
dirty they are checking the tennis balls
on a walker see what the story is these
things are brand new
[Laughter]
[ __ ] party's about to get turnt up
you hear that patty
you're proud of your past
no
but i'm working through it
it's okay
who said that not me i know that
that's not how you feel about it you put
on a good face for public
um
sure what the [ __ ] were we talking about
i got lost there for a second you're
talking about no one can go upstairs in
your house no not even before that that
no it wasn't for some reason it's just
like
my thing
even you don't let guests upstairs do
you put like a little rope on the bottom
of the staircase no you're completely
taking this out clothes for maintenance
you're taking this out of context what
is what other reason other than going
the bathroom
and why would you consider that's where
the video game console is and the kids
are up there playing i don't know
they're playing hide-and-go-seek they're
playing kids that's what i'm saying kids
are different obviously if the kids are
running around playing
but like unless you're going up there
to [ __ ] there's no other reason to go
upstairs at someone's house take a nap
that's what i'm saying you shouldn't be
taking a nap at a [ __ ] family party
you gotta lay off the sauce
hey can i go lay down i got the spins
that boone's farm is really kicking in
the [ __ ] in that martinelli's god damn
oh brook linen brook linen brooklyn man
i'm talking about i feel like i
shouldn't even be saying that word it's
so classy classy brook linen is all
right gang do yourself a favor season
for gift giving stop by brooklyn and get
somebody you care about a nice set of
sheets
perfect presents for everyone on your
wish list they got stuff for the house
the bath the bedroom everything at all
um brooks brooklyn's goal was to create
beautiful high quality home essentials
that don't that don't break the bank
it's perfect place to find the best gift
um they started out with betting and now
they have like we said all the
essentials for every corner of the home
whatever you want they got it betting's
top shelf um brooklyn's comfort game is
unmatched and their lineup keeps getting
better and if you're looking for more
ways to stay cozy check out brooklyn's
candles eye masks and accessories take
all the guesswork out of gift giving
this time of year uh with comfy crowd
pleasers from brooklyn
they send it they send them to us i got
the towels dude i feel like i'm in i
feel like i'm in the ritz in these
things those candles fill the entire
room i'm gonna tell you that right dude
the towels are like a weighted blanket
that's nice you're engulfed in these
things it's fantastic so give the gift
of comfort this holiday season and save
while you do it go to brooklyn.com use
promo code garbage for 20 off with a
minimum purchase of 100 we're talking
cold hard cash 20 off with a minimum
purchase of 100 that's brooklyn
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com enter promo go
garbage for 20 off with a minimum
purchase of one hundred dollars small
bills too do it gang let's talk about
the good people that manscaped man scale
we were talking about him last time
you're talking about office romances i'm
just saying it's the time of year people
are drinking you're hanging happy hours
office party punch balls on your head
next thing in your underwear is on
backwards you want to becoming correct
down there that's all i'm saying
talking like we live in an 80s movie or
something that's where you're putting
yourself hey man reality is whatever you
make it wish it would have had that in
the 80s because manscape keeps
everything nice and tight and clean the
motor is real powerful it doesn't make a
lot of noise you can use it in the
shower it's got a light on it i'm
telling you man this thing is a game
changer and as we said last week
the before and after photos
you wouldn't even recognize i know
yeah uh
and did you guys with this holiday
season around the corner ladies if
you're a lady listener which we got a
lot of lady listeners it's a great gift
to get your man keep them you know it's
you can tell them to be like hey keep it
tight down there it's a gift for you too
it's a gift for everybody it's a gift
for the household not pulling pubes out
of here and maybe the neighbors if you
don't have blind
[Laughter]
but someone got me
it's perfect for uh any guy or gal in
your life it's fantastic stocking stuff
or whatever you want it's they got it
all so just go check out manscaped um
and manscape.com with pro code garbage
you'll save 20 off plus free shipping
it's easy peasy whether it's your
partner your dad your brother your
friend get him the gift that'll actually
and then plus it'll get a laugh too you
want to kill her on a christmas tree get
someone a ball trimmer
i don't really start the party hey
grandpa here you go you got 20 off and
free shipping at manscape.com promo code
garbage be the ballsiest gift giver this
year with landscape now back tennis show
all right let's see um what was the
original question that's what i'm trying
to get back to i kind of couldn't
remember um oh where do you put the
towel that's what
oh and then the grandparents my grandma
finally said i used to get out i used to
leave we had a towel rack on the back of
the door at my mom's upstairs you have
to get out to reach it no but it was you
couldn't reach it from the like i mean
it was what i'm saying you would have to
get out of the tub to walk and like it
was like five paces or whatever and i
would just stand there soaked soaking
the whole [ __ ] and then finally my
grandmom's like what do you do you don't
dry off over the bath matter and i'm
like
i never even crossed my mind so now i do
i do up to the legs and then i get out
and do the legs you know um i don't want
my towel touching the bathtub really
huh
um
you know you're in a really nice shower
or a really nice hotel when there's a
towel rack in the shower yeah that's
good where like the water is the thing
is so big that's so big the shower
yeah yeah some of the trashy ones put it
in there even though it's like a regular
size excuse me it was [ __ ] soaked the
towel over the um
over the shower curtains trash too
that's what i do really well ours what
are you in the navy what we have um
we have a tower act that i just don't
use for some reason
the one half of mine's kind of open
like the
if th
you're not going to wrap your head
around this uh
you have one of those that you have the
your faucet's in the middle of the tub
middle
yeah
yikes but it is like a waterfall john
and it comes straight down to them it's
nice okay that part's good i'm not
trying to say it's but the one side by
the shower is open kind of i know
exactly what you're talking about yeah
it doesn't go all the way around like
you you have a basin tub a lion's foot
tub whatever ryan's foot lion's claw no
you don't gotta be talking to you if i
had a [ __ ] lion's tooth tub my
brother's got lion's face
really old-school deep tubs yeah they've
never [ __ ] used it they don't use it
i'm like have you taken a bath in there
yet like now we have that i'd be in
there all the i'd be getting calls in
there
that's where i would run the operation
from what operation get some things
dominoes
you still doing the five five five
what's the deal
um yeah i know i hang over that
just because it's like so you have a
round
shower curtain it goes from the wall and
around no all right so
i knew this is like a three stooge
that's no no no no it goes from the wall
and then cur it's like yeah curves but
the whole thing isn't curved it curves
at the turn does that make sense it's
like an l
i don't know i know you don't know that
sounds like lower east side [ __ ] to me
tenement
listen you live in astoria which stinks
by no way toby and i were talking about
it that that place is going to be dude
rodeo driving a couple of years place is
classy it's [ __ ] stinky i was just
back over there everybody's honking
there's [ __ ] traffic it you're under
the subway there's an elevated subway it
stinks crazy it prop you can hear the
train at every apartment you can hear
the train rattling it stinks you where
else have you lived by the way i was
thinking this yesterday you've never
lived anywhere else that's not true
recently i'll tell you recently i've
lived i grew up i lived in wilkes-barre
i lived in belgium i'm saying in new
york in philly
south philly i lived in wow north
carolina
yeah no all right no
upper east side murray hill brooklyn
bushwick
sunset park reggie and cotton
um
i'm saying you still go with a chicken
harlem
a couple of times oh man i remember her
um
cut that
uh but i'm saying as in a i mean you
were an adult through 97 of those houses
but i'm saying as a financially
relatively independent adult relatively
well the first time you were on a lease
in the past decade
has only been in astoria there was yeah
the the apartment that the building was
the building you're in now that's what
i'm saying yeah first that's all you
know
yeah as in a as a red painted utility
holding adult is a story you don't know
anything else
yeah what's your point
a story is thanks no you're stupid i've
lived in both it stinks it proper stinks
let's move on let's agree to disagree no
that's what losers say
we were in the car and he started this
exact rap and i was like just wait wait
in my head i was like wait 30 seconds 30
seconds later you go see the scrape is
coming up you know i could really see
myself raising the kid here i was like
where's the crazy gonna come there there
it is why is that crazy it's like
whack-a-mole you're like i know no
whammy no whammy no whammy here's why is
that crazy because you were reminiscing
about a situation we were currently in
i remember eating hot dogs there last
week
i gotta have a kid out here
[Laughter]
all right
fair enough
back to the queues there
bozo
uh this one's great uh this is from tom
level 10 homie never had it
had one red
you ever been to a store that changed
what it sold during the year a place in
my town sells ski gear in the winter and
patio furniture in the summer that is a
tough look those halloween pop-ups are
weird yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel like
they just live in the back of a tractor
trailer the rest of you they probably do
yeah we have we have oh yeah people that
work there we have an empty which i
think it used to be a gas station so
it's like an empty lot
and
there's selling different things in
there throughout the year wow and i
don't know if it's the same it's like
christmas tree
flowers
when you could whatever you know just
like random [ __ ] depending on the sear
probably patio furniture when you can
recognize what it used to be is a tough
look like when you know that insurance
office used to be a pizza hut pizza
hut's a bad one wendy's is a bad one too
because they had the sun room yeah yeah
yeah yeah wawa's too the old oh well
that's when it's not oh you're going to
a dentist that's a wawa you're like what
the [ __ ]
still has that smell uh
i gotta maggio um [ __ ] what was i just
gonna say jesus [ __ ] alzheimer andy
over here get folk you need a prevagen
or something an adderall god damn you
got any um
scam likely stop calling me uh-oh
all over the place i'm the one scamming
around here i really pissed off a
scammer two days ago
because i take the car they're wasting
their time
trying to burn and turn over here
they call me up and they say um they
leave a message very very authoritative
they're like uh uh this is for mr
michael foley um
you need to call us back right away a
matter of td bank boss touchdown bank
touchdown yeah they're [ __ ] dragging
them into the [ __ ] scam so i called
the guy back
um just to [ __ ] with them and i'm like
oh you know what what's going on they're
like um
this you wrote a check for 369 dollars
and it bounced and uh and our clients
trying us to recoup it
uh
like would you like to make that payment
today
what am i a [ __ ] sucker so i just
first of all i'm doing an old man's
voice i'm doing what what happened and
then right when he said can i get the
credit card information i'm like you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dirt bag you're
[ __ ] this guy calls me back yeah
[ __ ] piss well he can probably track
you down he did he knew my name and
everything yeah hey listen here you fat
[ __ ] i don't even like your podcast
it's just me that's real scummy though
man what you're calling and [ __ ]
trying to scam old people out of their
[ __ ] money because they do it does
that does that warranty thing work on
anybody does that work
like how dumb are we i'm sure some
people yeah who even has a warranty on
their car like that people old people
don't know do i have a warranty i
thought it said three thou i haven't
talked to the dealership okay it's i
told you i got my my boy big gay aunt's
mom or grandmom they were like hey this
is the las vegas pd we got your we got
your grandson
gonna be like you know two grand to get
him out or something and i'm pretty sure
she paid it jesus yeah something like
that or she called him like are you okay
i just got a whatever yeah that's real
[ __ ] up man
scammers yeah
um
all right let's see haven't had one uh i
haven't had one read yet this is from
missouri broad does anyone in your
family own a strobe light
[Laughter]
i used to
i used to have a strobe light and like
when in like eighth grade maybe when
spencer's gifts was like in full stride
give yourself a seizure
[Laughter]
we did have one friend who was epileptic
that we couldn't have you know we had to
unplug when he was around buzz killer
catch a heel hey mark go out in the
garage for a little while
i'm trying to get weird try to get my
rave
a disco ball oh how weak are you that
you can get taken out by a flashlight
yeah well i don't know man the first
time they put that on oh yeah your
screwballs it's like it's like blade i
don't know what's happening that's like
the gravitron the gravitron almost
killed me one time
i swear to god it starts revolving
around you
a black guy
[Laughter]
doctor who steps out yeah
um
that was my favorite ride hands down
ever why would boardwalk gravatron
maurice pier go down there up on the
left right before you get to the
nor'easter love the [ __ ] gravitron
yeah i loved it i could do everything i
could go upside down i could lean out
and touch the puzzle doing tricks in
there really yeah i'm pretty good that
dude in the center was a pedophile
no doubt that was pre-wreck yeah
that was a good time dirt ball um
cranking journey
uh
yeah strobe lights are trashy they're
the trashiest you walk in in somebody's
basement they have a [ __ ] disco ball
yeah it's [ __ ] yeah dirtbag city
that's a big thing people try to do is
like the bar that never gets used right
you're talking about the basement ball
oh yeah my dad had a hot one in the 80s
unless you're really entertaining but
you're not i don't think people are
doing that that much glasses are dusty
yeah you get down there like no one's
been down i can feel the energy no one's
been down here in six months you know
what i mean and then they're like let's
hang it down it's all got the wife and
kids breaking his balls they're like how
do you go down like let's hang at the
ball you're just like sitting down there
you're like this is so set up we're all
just acting like we're not you know
we all know what's going on here this
stinks what are we doing there's a
bedroom right next to me forgot for
crying out loud
the bedroom in the basement yeah yikes
uh all right this one's for what
no no
i never liked the bedroom in the bed
like i just slept in one last weekend
put in my brother's guest bedroom
downstairs yeah well there's yeah
there's a guest bedroom downstairs and
it's on the far end on the far side away
from the stairs and i need about 37
beers for me to go night night in there
because it gets scary
[Laughter]
the spiders have spiders oh man
it's real [ __ ] sketchy
i ain't doing that all right this one's
from rj i haven't had a question read
yet ever steal a street sign
which i'm sure we've mentioned before
100
uh i don't know if i've ever had a
proper street sign the big one that was
in sea isle city that would get stolen
all the time because there was pleasure
avenue
and 69th street
69th street and pleasure would get
stolen like
weekly to the point where i think they
just stopped putting it up because
they're like
so many drunk people would be walking
home from the bar yeah give me this my
fraternity
was mostly engineers
and so
sounds like a real [ __ ] party house
hey equals mcg squared shut up nerd
we made the world's fastest beer bomb
yeah wow what a what a great improvement
let's go
uh no i'm sure you guys were batting
away with this stick
that come with your own pocket
protectors or what do you guys have to
do
hey for pledge everybody studies 37
hours go
everyone's got tape on their glass real
[ __ ] nerd dude the party last night
was crazy hank put together an erector
he was blindfolded
i was up until nine
that's the fraternity you've been
bragging about engineers
this whole time
train engineers
they're a wild bunch they all got to hat
on in the overalls
it was a party house man we had a good
time um anyway they could everybody's
drinking out of beakers and stuff
fully just did 37 milliliters
don't do it mean
you stink
dude that and someone tweeted the clip
of when you were talking about the glory
days in college football and i said you
you were gigantic who played d3
piece of [ __ ]
oh foley's glory days i want to see how
you view them in your head what
soundtracks playing and stuff like that
pearl jam probably um
anyway anywho these guys were pretty
good and they could like take [ __ ] and
put [ __ ] apart
um put [ __ ] apart
they could take things apart and put it
back together they stole a uh a light a
traffic light like a proper traffic
light brought it in [ __ ] hooked it up
it's [ __ ] cool for like 10 minutes
yeah still pretty sweet
sounds it okay
i mean i don't know why you try to go
back you thought i mean we just made fun
of you and these guys for like 12
minutes you thought a cool traffic light
story was going to button it up foley
get in here we're building each other
girlfriends
we all got bras on their heads like in
weird signs
just waiting for a thunderstorm and
we'll be a-okay
[Laughter]
wait for us
we just need some purple lightning and
she'll be alive
and you stink dude that movie talk about
[ __ ] spank bank that was too i was
too yeah you were i was way too young
dude weird sign anthony michael hall
was so [ __ ] funny yeah i saw him one
time
really yeah he was a real dick what yeah
you know my friend
uh keep this vague our friend that works
in hotels in boston
yes uh
they were working a
very nice hotel
and he came in as like real vip or like
thought he was this is like
2017. i don't know yeah and he was had
all these demands and he had a hot piece
hot little number one i remember this
story yeah he was like had all these
demands was actually like a real [ __ ]
jerk off and it's like sucks dude you
had your last movie was 35 years ago i
loved him as a kid [ __ ] weird science
16 candles [ __ ] kid did it for me
loved them
that's sad to see
[Laughter]
all them let's do a couple of more you
said that like you're a more successful
guy
yeah
hate to see it happen he was a good kid
i wish him well now anyhow can someone
tie my shoes
michael if you're watching reach out to
me so i can see if we can help you out
hate to see it happen yeah good kid
give me a call
man this is a fun one let's go bozo
making fun of my fraternity friends it
was a [ __ ] cool house
we used to have parties where we were
handing out joints
there's only a couple guys there
we did it we did every time a girl
showed up
we all panicked
[Laughter]
it was it was johnson's sister but still
everybody played cool mahoney's mom came
one time everybody passes out
[Laughter]
we all feed it there's a couple of wine
coolers in the fridge if you want them
we did have a sorority cancel on a mixer
one time
man
hey that fat one's not gonna be there is
he
i wasn't fat back then [ __ ]
they knew
i had a crystal ball
no way i'm getting tied down with this
elephant
guys bad news the girls found out were
[ __ ] dorks
who told them
i told you to keep your mouth shut until
they got here
who let feach man out of his room
ah we did have a kid what did they say
his nickname was
was fish man
he used to just [ __ ] huff nitrogen
and just [ __ ] pass out like a mummy
just fall back and hit his head
man he has never
[ __ ] beaten him off
huh why do why did the girls say they
canceled because we stunk
i know but what reason yeah we all have
a midterm in the morning
we got finals it's the beginning of
semester that's the third week classes
haven't even started
hey me and the girls talk we're all
going to stay virgin
no they didn't say anything we all
decided to save ourselves for not losers
i remember three of the worst ones
showed up and gave us the bad news hey
the rest of the girls aren't coming they
all went to a party but we're still down
party
oh man
they just came by to see if we had any
ice
[Laughter]
man
holy [ __ ] i didn't know you guys were
all engineers i wasn't a [ __ ]
engineer yeah
maybe that's where you were enrolled in
the eating also didn't graduate i said
some of the older guys were engineers
not like the whole house was i was the
[ __ ] living in the ghostbusters who
said i was in a fraternity full of
engineers yeah full of engineers that
was everybody was an engineer i was a
hotel restaurant manager
turned into a waiter slash pilhead
this is like an m night shyamalan level
twist i pledged [ __ ] my sophomore
year before i got to know the guys on
the lacrosse team if i would have known
the guys who were crossing i would have
pledged 5 second would have been okay
yeah it said you're over there with the
dorks on the chest team yeah
check and mate
[Laughter]
and that's how you play connect four
ladies
and that's how i touched a boo
all right let's just [ __ ] rap we
built the [ __ ] potato gun
he has a class project
as for the science fair
all right let's wrap it up
oh
god man i'll i'll never look at you the
same what are you talking about [ __ ]
you were it's all coming out you can
only lie for so long what do you mean we
were like we were the drug party we were
the drug party house there was just a
lot of engineers that were there they
were dorks anyway
we hated them the younger guys were all
myself toby cut this i got a rep to
protect
see you next week you are a dork dude
uh guys thank you so much uh come out i
don't know exactly when it's come out
but if uh it's for this week uh we're
gonna be an upstate new york and
connecticut come out to those 14th 15th
and 16th hartford albany syracuse yeah
also on the trail guys go subscribe to
the youtube page we have something
dropping
hint go subscribe right now it's going
to be really cool we don't want to look
like bozos appreciate all this all hands
on deck when this thing drops i
appreciate the support love you guys
love yous peace